[MUSIC PLAYING]
Millions of websites and apps
are using the Google Maps API
today, whether helping
users book a hotel
or find a great restaurant.
However, these maps have
always been isolated.
Favorite places saved
on one map won't show up
anywhere else on the web.
With the Google
Maps API signed-in
experience and attributed
save, your users
have the option to sign into the
map with their Google account.
Their saved places, such as
their home or work address,
will appear automatically
when they look at your map.
Additionally, with
attributed save,
you can allow users to
star places from your app
and display them on other
Google maps throughout the web.
When a user clicks on
one of your saved places,
they'll see a link
back to your site.
It's easy to get started with
just a single line of code.
See the tutorial on our
blog to get started today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]